First up, we have Kimberly Arthur-Mensa.
What is your question for Chip and Jo?
Yes, first off,
I love, love, love you guys.
Thank you.
And my question is home renovations, big or small,
can be very daunting.
What are some tips to stay motivated and get things done?
Ooh, I love that.
I always say, just start small.
It's kinda like anything in life,
like you can dream really big
but to really start getting things moving
and make things a reality,
you just gotta kinda look at the smallest thing,
tackle that, then go to the next thing
and just start getting your rhythm.
So for people that are trying to tackle, say a kitchen,
you know, it's like, "Hey, start with your backsplash
or start with new hardware."
Like you don't have to do the full renovation.
And sometimes, the greatest joy is when
you don't do the whole thing and you just do a few tweaks
and it changes the space on a really great budget.
So I always say start small
and work towards the bigger picture,
but don't try to get it all done at once.
Great question.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
She's beautiful.
That's really, really smart, hardware
can change everything.
Not just hardware.
All right, next, we have Yolette, guys.
What is your question for Chip and Jo?
My question to you is you have five beautiful children,
and I imagine a couple of 'em are picky.
So what do you do to get them to try new things?
That's kind of your thing.
Sort of my cup of tea,
Jo is also picky.
So she encourages,
I like mac and cheese...
She encourages the children to think very small
and think very-
I cook the same things
every week.
Unadventurous.
That's really what I do.
Yeah.
And I'm always trying to teach 'em that,
look, new things are what teach us new things.
You know, how else are you gonna learn
if you don't try something new?
So I'm constantly pushing that envelope.
But I will say I've met my match
in the sense that some human beings are so stubborn
they refuse to try new things.
(laughs) That's me.
No matter how hard you try.
Yeah.
But I will say as a Testament to Joanna Stevens-Gaines,
if she can do it, anybody can do it.
Amen.
We'll be here all week,
ladies and gentlemen.
Oh my gash.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Good to see you.
Thanks for that question.
You bet.
Oh, thank you.
Nice to meet you.
All right, Kimberly Skarren,
what is your question for Chip and Jo?
What is one design trend from the past
that you hope never returns?
(Chip laughs)
I feel like I asked you that
Popcorn ceiling.
Popcorn ceiling's an easy one.
I think we-
Did we see that ever coming?
Unanimous in that sense, yeah.
Shag carpet, I think maybe that's even debatable now
Well, 'cause now you've got some really amazing shag rugs.
The texture.
But I will say
I'm gonna rat Jo out here for a second,
if I might?
Oh, great.
Do it.
I'm ready.
The first project we ever did was this great little house,
over just on the other side of town.
And it had four or five major areas to the house.
Jo had not found her design aesthetic quite yet,
and Jo literally went through that project
and each room was like walking into a brand new,
different themed-
It was a themed house.
Joanna said yes to a different theme
in every room in that first house.
Didn't you?
I sure did.
All right. But then what happens?
Like how do you then find out
what actually is your cup of tea?
And I was like,
"What room do I love the feeling of the most?"
And then our second house,
then that became three out of the five rooms.
But I was just experimenting as we were going.
We were experimenting.
I'm still trying to
figure out what went really well.
We were experimenting
and the next thing you know, four kids, you know?
(audience laughs)
Here we are,
back to square one.
Have a wonderful day.
Thank you for the question.
Thank you for being with us.
We're gonna be here all weekend.
Thank you, ladies and gentlemen, yeah.
(bright music)